[Music]
welcome to the hubermann lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
[Music]
i'm andrew huberman and i'm a professor
of neurobiology and ophthalmology at
stanford school of medicine
recently i had the pleasure of hosting
two live events one in seattle
washington and one in portland oregon
both entitled the brain body contract
where i discussed science and science
related tools for mental health physical
health and performance my favorite part
of each evening however was the question
and answer period that followed the
lecture i love the question and answer
period because it gives me an
opportunity to hear directly from the
audience as to what they want to know
most and the need to get into a bit of
dialogue so we really clarify what are
the underlying mechanisms of particular
tools how best to use the tools for
things like focus and sleep we also
touched on some things related to mental
health and physical health it was a
delight for me and i like to think that
the audience learned a lot i know that
many of you weren't able to attend those
events but we wanted to make the
information available to you therefore
what follows this is a recording of the
question and answer period from the
lecture in portland oregon i hope you'll
find it to be both interesting and
informative i'd also like to thank our
sponsors of these live events the first
is momentous supplements which is our
partner with the hubermann lab podcast
providing supplements that are of the
very highest quality that ship
international and
that are arranged in dosages and single
ingredient formulations that make it
possible for you to develop the optimal
supplement strategy for you and i'd also
like to thank our other sponsor which is
inside tracker which provides blood
tests and dna tests so you can monitor
your immediate and long-term health
progress i'd also like to announce that
there are two new live events scheduled
the first one is going to take place
sunday october 16th at the wilton
theater in los angeles the other live
event will take place wednesday november
9th at the beacon theater in new york
city tickets to both of those events are
now available online at hubermannlab.com
tour that's hubermanlab.com
tour i do hope that you learn from and
enjoy the recording of the question and
answer period that follows this
and last but certainly not least thank
you for your interest in science
[Music]
[Applause]
what are the current best practices for
post tbi traumatic brain injuries for
those of you that aren't familiar with
tbi especially long-term multiple
etc thoughts on hyperbaric oh i'm so
glad you asked this danny mortgage and
his treatment for tbis
okay tbi now one thing about tbi and
concussion everyone thinks football
guess what most of the tbi is not
football there aren't that many football
players they're just large so they stand
out
there might be a few here this evening
of course football players are a concern
when it comes to tbi most
head injuries are going to be
construction workers have you ever seen
the hard hats they wear those
i don't even know if they
are just there for show it doesn't make
sense and that we actually have a lab at
stanford that's focused very hard on
trying to solve this problem
so construction workers car accident
bicycle accidents portland amazing city
to cycle
i'm frankly afraid to cycle you're a
small moving object around these big
objects and people are staring to their
little aperture on their phone while
driving i mean whatever happened to that
by the way of not texting while driving
somehow that just disappeared it's like
it really has just disappeared there was
all this science showing that it's worse
than drunk driving and look
tbi
well the basic rules of the don'ts apply
if you get a head injury don't get a
second a head injury
but that often isn't feasible for people
that you know need to work continue
working construction
or that are struggling what do we know
well
this is a great opportunity for me to
distinguish
modulatory foundational tools from
things that directly change your brain
and nervous system the way that you want
to what do i mean by modulatory
we hear so much and there's so many
studies showing that great sleep quality
nutrition
good social interactions avoiding
chronic stress
and on and on and on are important for
everything reduced they're related to
alzheimer's they're related to adhd i
mean we could do thousands of podcast
episodes just returning to the same 10
things sleep
not don't stress too much or too long
good social connection avoid toxic
people
eat good food not too much processed
food we could have an argument all night
and i don't want to have one about
whether or not it's mainly plants or
this i mean on the inter this is you
know obviously eating high quality food
is something that we should all be doing
which foods you select is a topic that
is very barbed wire and i can give only
my opinions
all of that modulates your brain
function but it doesn't mediate or
change anything directly it's setting a
foundation of what's possible so we
should all be doing those things and
especially people who have tbi
now
this question relates to hyperbaric
chamber hyperbaric chamber there's very
interesting data it's essentially
hyperoxygenation of the brain for very
brief periods of time
i think the data on
hyperbaric chamber and tbi are very
encouraging the problem is
much in the way that a few years ago
cryo was only available in a few places
and now people are doing ice baths and
cold showers on their own it's hard to
find a hyperbaric chamber they aren't
just laying around and they don't have
them at spas typically and they are
quite expensive so yes they there are
interesting and important data i think
on hyperbaric chamber you definitely
want to work with a physician
or somebody who is very skilled a
practitioner who's very skilled in
hyperbaric chamber they do seem to
improve brain function by hyper
oxygenating the brain for periods of
time seems to improve a number of things
but above all it seems to improve the
quality and duration of sleep which
indirectly
allows the brain to repair itself
because as i mentioned earlier brain
repair occurs where brain change largely
occurs in sleep so if you don't have
access to hyperbaric chamber but you do
have tbi what are some of the other data
what do those point to
well i go on and on and you don't have
to get this from supplements you can get
it from food but this threshold level of
essential these epa essential fatty
acids there are now so
many data so much data on
the valuable role of these essential epa
fatty acids thresholds being somewhere
between one and two grams per day of the
epa
so much so
actually that there are now prescription
forms of epa that doctors are starting
to prescribe for people with tbi
although for most people you can get
this through you can look up and we've
done podcast episodes about different
ways to access this also functions as an
antidepressant equally good believe it
or not in clinical trials to
ssris
it once one gets over the one or
basically two grams per day of the epa
that the resident expert on the internet
about this is pretty extreme about the
dosages and that's dr rhonda patrick who
by the way deserves a a nod of of
acknowledgement and support because
it turns out that before me or david
sinclair or matt walker any of these
guys were blabbing
to the world about stuff that they had
learned in the you know archives of
science and in their laboratories
the first person in was this woman named
rhonda patrick as far as i know the
first public-facing formerly trained
scientist to start going on all these
podcasts and risk her reputation and
the kind of stuff that you deal with
when you put your neck out there like
that and and rhonda's i think terrific
we don't agree on everything and it
would be weird if we did
but i think she's really been the
proponent of of these higher doses of
epas for tbi and for cognitive function
into all ages
we often hear about ways to increase
dopamine however
are there effective ways to decrease
dopamine when you get too much of it for
certain behaviors or habits we want to
break katie
ham i think is the last name thank you
katie for your question yeah dopamine is
a is a slippery slope
and
dr onolemki is the expert in this and
we've had a lot of conversation she's
one of my closer friends on the faculty
unfortunately for her our coffee
discussions often last four hours or
more
her poor patients and family
here's the thing
when dopamine is higher in your brain
and body when you've deployed it through
excitement or pharmacology or otherwise
it tends to narrow your focus and make
you seek more of it in that general
theme that you happen to be focused on
could be anything
that's the scary thing about dopamine
what can you do to control it and to
reduce it well
for those of you that
are engaging in habits that are healthy
maybe that doesn't require reducing
dopamine how do you define healthy
versus unhealthy well i think the
simplest way to define addiction at
least by my mind is that addiction is a
progressive narrowing of the things that
bring you pleasure and a good life is a
progressive expansion of the things that
bring you pleasure
a rather simple definition and yet when
we think about the biology of dopamine
dopamine is not unique to one pursuit
it's not unique to pursue the pursuit of
sex or the pursuit of warmth when you're
cold or
cool environments when you're too warm
or food or social media it's just a dumb
molecule that puts you into this forward
state of
mass
small visual aperture and a kind of
obsessive like nature what can you do to
counter that well the best thing to do
is to not get into that state too long
but if you do
the best thing you can do
is to try and switch off that system not
through pharmacology but by not pursuing
more dopamine
the day after a big event the so-called
postpartum depression named of course
because of true postpartum after the
delivery of a child that's quite common
for people to get very very depressed
there's a lot of neurochemical and
hormonal adjustments that are occurring
but different types of postpartum
depression occur after a big party the
monday blues the sunday blues
the post-whatever blues
the
four-month mark in a relationship
is typically when dopamine starts to
drop i always tell people just wait i'm
telling somebody very close to me right
now just wait four months
four months four months and also spend
as much time with that person as
possible i don't know what this deal is
about not spending as much time with
people i think people are afraid that
the dopamine wave pool is just going to
pull them both under
i think they call that the escalator
model of relationship where you just
sort of find yourself in the
relationship because you went through
the stages without actually deciding on
them in any event
four months seems to be the stage in
which the dopamine crescendo starts to
relax a little bit not in a long
distance relationship however we know
this right anticipation is dopamine that
positive anticipation and there's a
whole
beautiful science of this in the and i
should say psychology of this there's a
wonderful book actually
uh the name of the book is embarrassing
always i don't know why for me to say
it's a it's by a psychologist called can
love last which is a psychoanalytic book
about this dopamine serotonin system and
the kind of seesawing back and forth and
the fact that in relationships people
often just slam on the dopamine side of
things and then they hit a wall and want
to break up or they go into this like
warm cozy fuzzy feeling thing and they
go well i guess the
exciting part is over and this idea that
one could actually or two people or
however many people were in portland
could oscillate this
seesaw
i don't think that you want to use
pharmacology to turn off the dopamine
system but
for people that have a hard time
sleeping and that are really in a state
of agitation and constantly obsessing
the psychiatrist one of the oldest and
most effective treatments
is that the psychiatrists and this does
have to be prescribed will use a very
very low dose of a dopamine receptor
blocker like haloperidol which is a used
to treat schizophrenia a very low dose
to shut down the
obsession component
smart well-educated psychiatrists know
this as a useful tool but this is a
one-time thing with a very low dose
because having your dopamine blocked
sucks it does not feel good but not
being able to sleep and being in an
obsessive mode also sucks so it's
actually a very potent clinical tool so
pharmacology should is one tool but
really at the far end of things i
believe that one should try and modulate
their own dopamine by not
rewarding
oneself on a regular basis but only
randomly random intermittent reward is
truly the best
schedule of reward hence slot machines
and so on and you should engage random
intermittent reward and i think this is
also the way that we should train kids
essential i call training kids you can
tell i don't have kids
the um
you don't reward them every time i don't
believe everyone should get a trophy
every time nor should you always just
reward the winners because those winners
often we see cases of this high profile
cases of this they often crash and burn
i mean the number of high performers
that crash and burn publicly and lord
knows how many do it privately is
remarkable it's because their dopamine
system is all messed up so random
intermittent reward is the schedule
reward that we should
impart on ourselves
if you had 10 minutes a day to improve
your brain plasticity what
would you do and when would you do it
richard conlon thank you
well
i'm going to say again i would
absolutely anchor my physiology with
morning sunlight viewing i can't help it
do you know what's interesting i'll tell
you very briefly you know what's special
about morning sunlight this lowing solar
angle sunlight i don't think i've talked
about this much on social media or on
the podcast there's a group at the
university of washington a couple jay
and maureen knights they run a lab
together that sounds like a horrible
thing but they do it and they get along
very well and they've discovered
that the cells in your eye the neurons
that set your circadian clock make you
alert during the day and make you sleepy
at night and so on
those cells respond best
to yellow blue contrast
and orange tones
now this is important
because when you go out in the morning
even if it's not at sunrise but it's
close to sunrise or you look at the sun
in the evening what you'll see is yellow
blue contrast or orange yellow blue
orange that old thing from kindergarten
or first grade
that's not the color of light that
you're going to see when the sun is
overhead now this also is really
interesting because
artificial lights at least to my
understanding even the daylight
simulators have not picked up on this
it's just about bright light
someone ought to design something that
can mimic this but nature has done this
beautifully for us and so viewing low
solar angle sunlight in the morning and
in the evening
is most effective because of those
yellow blue contrast now here's the
really wild thing
those circuits that set your levels of
alertness in sleep
yes they respond best to yellow blue
contrast but what that tells us is crazy
what that means is that color vision
was probably not related to color
perception first because all of that is
completely subconscious
the pathways that do this are present in
people who are pattern vision blind so
what do i mean i mean that color vision
likely evolved from a need to
synchronize your internal state with the
external world and the best stimulus in
the outside world to do that is yellow
blue contrast in other words our ability
to detect color was first and foremost
and we understand this based on
evolutionary genomics and so forth
to extract time of day information not
color of fruit or color of skin or
anything like that that's all secondary
which is wild and crazy and this is yet
another example of the way we think
things work is not the way they work
it's completely a 180 degrees opposite
i'm just going to give you a little
teaser i had a guest on the podcast he
hasn't we haven't aired the episode yet
his name is eric jarvis he works on
speech and language he also was admitted
in the alvin ailey dance company again
who are these people he's a professor at
the rockefeller
anyway
i learned from eric and you'll learn
when that episode comes out that you
only find elaborate speech and language
in species that also engage in dance and
song and the genomics point to the fact
that song and singing came first and
language came second
and that
led me during that episode of the
podcast i wrote down in my notes i was
listening to him talk and i wrote down
in my notebook it's just scrawled in big
letters it says i am so happy right now
i was just blown away i couldn't and it
makes so much sense when you hear it
that the colors in the sky were what we
our system is trying to extract not a
perception of those colors in the sky
because they're informing us about time
and orienting us in time
that song and the communication of
emotional states would be simpler and
more foundational than communication
about specific patterns of language
when you hear it suddenly it makes sense
but of course we're human beings and
unless you're eric jarvis or ally crum
or
anna lemke you think about all this
stuff backwards
as i do
how can i navigate my way through taking
supplements to optimize my health when
my career demands army infantry prevent
me from being able to establish
consistent routines andrew yogan well
thank you for doing what you do
andrew
so
the consistent routine thing is tough
you know
here are the
here's what i can say without going into
a long two and a half hour episode about
jet lag and shift work which we've done
the most powerful way to anchor your
brain and body in time is indeed viewing
light
sunlight at consistent times of day
that's not something i made up we we
know this
based on a lot of work that dates back
to the 1930s
the second most powerful stimulus is
going to be movement and changes in body
temperature in particular increases in
body temperature tend to make us alert
and decreases in body temperature and to
make us
sleepy body temperature drops one to
three degrees to get us into sleep why
does a cold shower wake you up
adrenaline is released and believe it or
not your body is heating up internally
to combat that cold unless you make
yourself hypothermic
so sauna
hot baths to get sleepy
cold showers ice baths etc to wake up
sort of obvious when you hear it but
it's counter-intuitive because you think
oh heating up the body to wake up and
cooling down the body to go to sleep so
getting in the cold ought to cool me
down but your body compensates just like
if you threw a cold towel on a
thermostat you'd crank up the
temperature in the room and vice versa
for heat okay
so what do you do you want to try and
use as many of these things light
temperature exercise food when you eat
is typically associated with waking
very few of us are capable of eating in
our sleep
and then the other one is social
activity and rhythms now the
discombobulated person is going to be
the person that has not aligned these
things in a consistent way so while
schedules vary and and i don't know your
exact schedule what i can say is if you
suddenly go from daytime
behavior and sleeping at night to the
so-called vampire shift as it's called
in the military and suddenly you're
up in the middle of the night and you're
sleeping during the day then when you
come off that shift
what you want to do is try and combine
as many of those same things at one time
so it would be get your sunlight so go
jogging without your sunglasses
drink your coffee engage with other
people and communicate eat a meal
afterwards or as the case may be before
try and bring as many of those things
together the same time of day for a few
days and pretty soon your system will
map around that
so the reason i encourage for
those of us that are not doing shift
work
to try and be fairly consistent about
sunlight viewing is it sets in motion
everything else that's correct but if in
terms of timing of eating
appetite will follow when your alert
will follow you'll start to learn your
own rhythms
when you
can't control your
schedule try and combine as many of
those cues again light temperature
exercise food social engagement into one
period of time and try and lock that
into a more or less a one or two hour
period or plus or minus one or two hours
at a particular time of day
for at least two or three days and your
schedule meaning your internal clocks
will lock to that
how is social media changing our brains
thomas
well you know you hear you hear all the
terrible ways in which it's changing our
brains and i think that
again we go back to this thing as is it
the aperture that we're looking at so is
it the format that we're engaging in
things
or is it
the content well the way i like to think
about the phone is the way that we've
been engaging with the phone and the
laptop for that matter in staring into
the small visual aperture each day is
sort of like walking like this all day
long
right we have this amazing ability to
shuffle our feet and take small steps or
to take big strides to run
to move
i think that's the sagittal plane for
movement i know it for the brain but it
always mess up the pts are vicious
people online by the way the pts and
nutrition people i've learned to just
not
not say anything about that i'm not a pt
and i'm not a physical therapist and
they they do incredible work but they're
like it's a very spirited crowd
and the nutrition thing is really weird
how they i mean it's just incredible
you're either people are either throwing
liver at you or they're throwing celery
at you or they're if they're fasting or
they're not fasting it's not
in any case
they social media and staring at a small
visual aperture is changing our brains
here's one way i know in which is
changing our brains and then i'll tell
you how to fix it
if you stare or look at something to
within two feet of you for a certain
number of hours each day your eyeball
actually gets longer
and the visual image then is focused in
front of your neural retina not onto
your neural retina and you are becoming
myopic
nearsighted and if you look at things in
the distance enough guess what your
eyeball changes shape and your lens will
focus appropriately the image onto your
retina take some work
kids that look at things up close too
much and adults that look at things up
close which become nearsighted
and there's a beautiful set of clinical
trials now
where
mainly in kids if kids get outside for
two hours a day getting a lot of this
uvb and blue light that we're told is so
terrible for us but they get it from
sunlight
they actually can reverse myopia or
reduce the incidence of myopia maybe
even glaucoma although that's a big
maybe
so
how much
staring into a small visual aperture is
too much
i don't know but what we do know is that
we are literally becoming myopic in
terms of our vision and we're becoming
myopic in terms of our cognition and
then there's the whole business of
what's actually contained in those
tweets and those social media feeds and
those news stories which frankly i feel
like you lose either way whether or not
you're in one political camp or another
political camp you're upset about half
of the information out there
so i feel like it's you know i and i'm
not
not someone who knows how to talk about
politics without stumbling
i didn't do well in social studies
um and this sort of thing
it just never made sense to me it just
felt like that the prize goes to the
person who can shout the loudest and the
most coherently for a moment so but i
encourage of course people to be
politically active
and i vote
but
but the
the content is tricky to navigate and i
can't really speak to that except that
it seems to be bothering everybody
on one side or the other or in the
middle
and
the format is something that we really
understand and again i don't know of
many people that are talking about this
narrow visual window format thing it
came up more during the lockdowns when
we were all inside a lot and not looking
out at a distance
the data say really to try and get at
least 10 minutes of long distance
viewing so longer than 10 feet
away from us for every 30 minutes of
close-up viewing and not a lot of us are
doing that if you're walking to your car
looking at your phone you're definitely
losing an opportunity
what new piece of neurological research
are you most excited about matteo monado
um
i think the the piece of neurological
research that all right the weird stuff
i've got this um colleague at stanford
tony weiss cory and they're really into
taking literally taking proteins from
young blood and young spinal cord uh
cerebral spinal fluid and putting it
into
older
people and animals and they get younger
that stuff's pretty wild um the fecal
transplant stuff is pretty wild right
you take the microbiome from one person
and
as it sounds you transplant it to
somebody else and they
take on the
physical characteristics of the donor
it's crazy until i talk to mike there's
some shouts for fecal transplant nice
i have never read the method sections of
those papers i'm actually afraid to read
the method sections
i
you know i would say this is not um
neurological but the work from chris
gardner and justin sonnenberg also at
stanford it makes it sound like i just
like stanford san francisco but these
are the people i'm closest to and
surrounded by there are excellent places
everywhere of course
um
including ohsu and i'm not just saying
that because i'm here actually close
colleagues here and friends here
at ohsu also amazing although that tram
thing freaks me out
it it's like i always just have all
these ideas about what's gonna happen if
that thing breaks but the
the
the
microbiome data are really interesting i
never understood why getting your gut
microbiome was important and it turns
out it's because your gut actually makes
many of the neurotransmitter precursors
that your brain uses
so that's pretty cool and
i always thought it would be a
complicated thing to get you got
microbiome right but it turns out that
it's
fermented foods that seem to have the
biggest effect there's all this argument
about fiber and yes fiber is important
and here i'm getting nervous talking
about nutrition because the people are
going to like come at me with fiber but
the um
but it's very clear from justin and
chris's data that
people who are getting four servings a
day of these fermented foods whether or
not it's kimchi or sauerkraut or
kombucha that stuff actually seems to
encourage a healthy gut microbiome
and people feel better and their immune
system works better and i like this
because it actually um it resolves an
issue which is that high-dose probiotics
these very expensive
need to be refrigerated things those
actually can create brain fog and other
issues they're for real severe cases of
dysbiosis so i always like an instance
where one can look to foods um which are
good because i like to eat
in order to resolve these issues
um in terms of other
neurologic issues i think that frankly i
think the stuff on dopamine is is is
fundamentally important so much
addiction that's a severe case but also
so much waxing and waning of of
motivation and once you understand the
dopamine system and you say what
activities am i engaging in or
pharmacology am i engaging in what am i
doing to spike dopamine you start to go
oh i get it the waves in this wave pool
are too high and that's why i can't do
this consistently and then you do the
counter-intuitive thing of approaching
things with a little less excitement but
then you're able to do them more
consistently it's like ah
and maybe with some luck i'll end up
finishing this book that i've been
working on for four and a half years as
a consequence because i can't seem to
thinking about the wim hof method do you
believe it
how is it really working what process is
happening in his brain oh boy um madison
cameron everyone here probably familiar
with wim hof um
whose uh occupation on wikipedia used to
be daredevil that was cool it's like
evil knievel had it and wim had it i got
a story about whim actually in 2016 i
heard about this guy wim hof
and i got a hold of him actually his
children
and i had one vacation that year and i
flew to
spain and i spent some time
mountaineering with wim which was
absolutely terrifying
i almost lost a leg
legitimately i tied in wrong on a bridge
sling he told me it was good for me he
told me to stare into the lizard's eyes
and i
st aired into the lizard's eyes i jumped
backwards off this homemade bridge sling
thing
and i had the rope wrapped through my
leg and it i came back with basically
the tendon on the back of my knee
exposed
and sitting next to me on the plane was
our vice dean of research at stanford
and i had to explain to him what i was
doing and why
it was very embarrassing
what did we do on that trip well a
couple of things that will help me
answer your question first of all when i
arrived i suffered terribly from jet lag
but the moment i got there wim did not
say hello he literally told me to get
into the ice bath and i did 10 minutes
in the ice bath not because i'm tough
but because he held me down in the ice
bath
he is indeed one of the strongest human
beings he reminds me of the bus driver
on the simpsons or the janitor excuse me
no otto is the bus driver right that the
janitor on the simpsons like oh that guy
that's whim incredibly physically strong
guy
what do i think is going on with wim hof
stuff well wim hof whether or not he
understands it or not
i always think he's sort of the bob
dylan of breath work like everything he
says seems to have some intuitive sense
but you don't really understand what in
the world he's saying
he's going to come after me now we've
got we've had a good but complicated
relationship i'll just confess maybe
someday we'll resolve that um no big
scandal or story there just we
communicate very differently
um
wim
has a couple methods one is to hype
deliberately hyperventilate there's also
called tumor breathing my lab actually
studies this we have a paper that i'm
happy to share with you the results so
they're not published yet where people
do deliberate cyclic hyperventilation
which as the name suggests you just
breathe really deeply in and really
deeply out 25 times or if your whim you
say no no no no i just tell people
here's how it works you go
you do that 25 times and you heat up and
you feel really agitated and that's
because of adrenaline
if you
throw yourself into an ice bath or a
cold shower adrenaline
if somebody upsets you or you get a
triggering text adrenaline
adrenaline sounds like a terrible thing
except when you deliberately induce it
as my colleague david spiegel says
there's a big difference between going
into a state and you controlling your
entry into a state so it's not just
about the state you're in it's about how
you got there and whether or not you had
anything to do with it
states of high adrenaline are very
powerful when you self-induce adrenaline
by cold shower
cyclic hyperventilation aka wim hof
breathing or tumor breathing you then
have an opportunity to create a very
distinct mind-body relationship we all
hear that interoception and the
mind-body relationship interoception
just your ability to sense your
heartbeats and what's going on in your
body powerful right
terrible if how you feel sucks
so
interoception is wonderful
but when you're anxious it actually is
more adaptive to be able to maintain
your thinking and get yourself out of
that anxious state so if you're
trembling and your body's freaking out
and your cheeks are flushing and you
and your brain is following your bodily
state well that's not good
and if you're somebody and sadly this
happens a lot where you've experienced a
lot of trauma or typically this is
people that bombarded with
extreme criticism or
physical abuse or other kinds of abuse
during development they actually can
seem very calm but internally they're
freaking out in their head and they're
just thinking just get me through this
and they just go into a state where no
one knows they're upset
i've known people like this and it's
eerie to me because i've never had that
response
to stress but it's very common and so we
should learn and be careful about
deciding that people are in one state or
another based on their bodily or their
mental response
wim hof breathing cold showers
etc
are a great practice in my opinion
because they allow you to spike your
adrenaline and you can do that
for instance by making the water colder
if you want more adrenaline staying in
longer if you want more adrenaline
moving your limbs around in the water
will give you more adrenaline because it
breaks up that thermal layer it makes it
a lot colder
or doing 50
deep inhales and exhales
that is very useful because then you
have the opportunity to use that
prefrontal cortex and to stop
and sense all that adrenaline in your
body and yet maintain clarity of mind
and that's an absolutely
powerful tool i would even call it a
power tool and wim figured this out i
don't know if you know this but the way
that wim discovered all this was he was
in deep grief about the tragic death of
his wife she committed suicide jumped
off an eight-story building
just truly tragic death and he was
in situation he had four children
at the time now he has five
and
he was in a state of depression and he
ended up going into the canal
in amsterdam and it was very cold and it
shocked his system
and in that
shock to his system which is caused by
adrenaline he somehow was able to anchor
his thinking and in a kind of
genius of sorts
wow i can intervene in my physiology
with this strange activity and then he
realized that breathing would do it as
well you didn't have to get into cold
water and then years later we discovered
not we meaning my lab but
other labs that when you get into cold
water even just 60 degree water that
there's a very long lasting increase in
dopamine that is 2.5
x above baseline which is
on par with some prescription drugs for
increasing dopamine so when people laugh
at me oh this cold water thing i get
teased a lot on the internet i've heard
on the internet that i that i eat sticks
of butter which i never said i said i
like i said i like butter i've been told
i've been told all sorts of things i've
been told i eat sticks of butter
like i don't know why i've been told
that i'm dead that was an interesting
one that was one of the cooler ones the
um
but you know when i was going out there
as a serious scientist and saying you
know using deliberate cold exposure you
can use all sorts of things or you know
if you come to my lab i'll be happy to
put you in vr and expose you all sorts
of scary stuff where we can inject you
with adrenaline or you can inject
yourself with adrenaline and titrate
that adjust the levels of that so it's a
very powerful tool and i think that whim
and others deserve credit for really
tapping into that and as a last point
there's a beautiful study in the
proceedings of the national academy of
sciences years ago
using this deliberate cyclic
hyperventilation thing 25 breath
and then another group meditates and
then they inject them both with e coli
and the people injected with e coli who
meditate get nauseous vomit diarrhea and
they get a fever and the people who
first
far fewer symptoms if any why because
adrenaline actually suppresses
a lot of these
innate immune responses in a way that's
healthy in the short term this is why
you can work work work work work or you
can study for finals you can take care
of a loved one and then you finally stop
and rest and go on vacation and then you
get sick
stress activates
your nervous system and in doing so it
activates your immune system makes
perfect sense when you think about it
how would we ever go through famine if
you're just getting flus whenever you're
stressed we can deal with a lot my
suggestion is if you're coming off a
period of high stress to do some sort of
adrenaline spiking behavior as you taper
out of that stressful period not going
strictly to massage vacation and yoga
nidra all day long as i would
reflexively do can red light therapy
help treat exercise intolerance and
fatigue and mitochondrial disease alison
i'm glad you brought this up there you
know this is another case where i
thought oh no this red light stuff is
crazy and then i went into the
literature it turns out that in 1908 the
nobel prize was actually given for photo
therapy
so there we go again and here you know i
have this slide i chose not to use
slides tonight but i have this slide
that shows um ken keysi and the magic
boss and stuff from the 1930s and
psychedelics and people getting into
cold water and then here we are 2019
2020 you've got wim hof and matt johnson
giving people macrodoses of psilocybin
we're right back where we were
and one of my major goals is to really
try and
create some
scientific discussion around these
things this stuff is
crazy on the face of it but there are
mechanisms that are real that underlie
it red light because it's long
wavelength light
longer literally as opposed to short
wavelength light can penetrate through
things like skin and can indeed change
mitochondria one of the more impressive
results on red light comes from my good
friend glenn jeffrey's lab at the
university of college london
i've known glenn for years in a few
years he was a basic vision scientist
and a few years ago he started using
red light he'd have people look at red
light at a distance of about two feet in
the morning so this is long wavelength
light
and sometimes even just take a
flashlight a torch as they call it in
england
and cover it with a red film and they
would look at this stuff for a few
minutes each morning and it
can reverse some forms of age-related
vision loss and macular degeneration how
we now know it can improve mitochondrial
function in photoreceptors by reducing
what are called reactive oxygen species
here's what's interesting it only seems
to work in people older than
40
and it seems to only work if you do it
within the first three hours of waking
and the incredible thing is you can do
this for one or two minutes a week and
some of the positive effects last as
long as three weeks and it's affecting a
very specific form of visual improvement
which is acuity kind of fine detail
stuff in my particular wavelength so
particular colors and objects and things
pretty impressive so yes red light can
improve mitochondrial function to the
photoreceptors if you are going to try
and do this stuff don't put it too close
i don't have any affiliation in any red
light panel
companies so i can't say anything there
they are rather expensive nowadays
people are putting red light everywhere
and i do mean everywhere
people are putting red light on their
stomach for improving ovarian function
whether or not i can penetrate isn't
clear to me all the way down there
people are trying to do this
uh
i have a friend i won't name him
recently he told me he's really into the
red light therapy he's putting it on his
testicles to try and increase
testosterone but he told me that after
he handed me the red light
true story
my team knows who this is it's no one on
my team thank goodness i was like oh
that's super interesting
i actually don't think you want to
contact the red lights directly to your
skin so red light is powerful i don't
think we have aside from the vision
protocol i don't think that it's clear
which protocols are best i will say if
you're into red light infrared sauna
typically those don't get hot enough
typically if you want to get the
benefits of sauna you want to get
between 80 and 100 degrees
celsius which is 176
to
210 or 208 fahrenheit and i i don't
actually do the conversion in my head
and memorize it you mentioned the
consequences of blasting your brain with
too much dopamine is it possible to
overdo ice baths while following the
same line of thinking will you
experience extreme low in dopamine with
too many ice baths lucy
thank you for the question
any behavior that spikes adrenaline you
will eventually get better at tolerating
it you will become cold adapted and you
will become comfortable at high
adrenaline states and you just have to
ask yourself this it's just like lifting
weights in the gym or running
you need to leave some space for
improvement
so if you run as people do and you do
your half merit your 5k then your 10k
then your half marathon maybe a 10k is a
half marathon i don't know but anyway
then you're doing your marathon then
you're doing ultras that are 50 miles
and 100 miles i mean eventually you're
going to start doing damage right and
eventually
you look at every ultra runner and
typically these are people
who are very much on the dopamine
pursuit system i mean i don't think that
he would mind my my good friend and a
podcaster who i have tremendous respect
for is you know rich roll
amazing human being and also has an
amazing story about addiction he was an
alcoholic i'm not sharing anything that
he hasn't already shared
in this amazing book finding ultra
you know he got really into running
running running all the time and you
know there's a dopamine history there
for him some of us
can use ice baths so consistently and
making it so cold and doing them longer
and longer that indeed you're playing
with the dopamine system is it bad well
it depends on what you're trading that
in for
you know at the expense of what as a
giving up cocaine yeah great stick with
the ice bath
but you know you can only make it so
cold and you can only stay in there so
long before you become wim hof
right and it worked out for whim
but there's really only one vim hof
and in general that's that speaks to a
larger theme which is i love the idea of
people using tools and understanding
mechanism i mean of course i love that
it's what i talk about and think about
so much of my my life
but for most of us we don't make a
living doing those things and so i do
think that the ideal situation is to
have behaviors and tools that you
intersperse throughout your day and
throughout the week for instance i think
three times a week is fine for the ice
bath no one said you had to do it every
day
but you should see sunlight every
morning if you can
just because if you miss a day your
system will be fine just spend twice as
long outside the next day seriously
because it's a slow integrating system
but you know
for most of these high intensity things
the less often you do them the more
powerful they are in fact if you get
into a very hot sauna for three four
excuse me 30 minute sessions on one day
so you go 30 minutes get out for five
minutes 30 minutes get out for five
minutes three minutes get out from it
two hours a day in the song that's a lot
of sauna but the growth hormone released
from that type of
protocol
is a 16x impro increase in growth
hormone this has been measured in humans
whereas if you do it every day or three
or four times a week you get diminishing
returns on that
so i actually am a big fan of doing
really intense stuff only every once in
a while
this is also why i only take one long
run per week or one long hike first of
all i don't have time for it i'm not an
ultra runner i got other things to do
and second of all it's a strong stimulus
i'm sore until tuesday or i don't want
to run until tuesday anyway i actually
think that's fine and i actually
encourage kind of more healthy rational
schedules of these kinds of behaviors
there's no
rule that says you have to do something
every day even if you're trying to
engage neuroplasticity you can learn
french
or an instrument by practicing
three times a week as long as your
practice is very focused
right
daily perhaps would be better but
very few of us have the opportunity to
do things every day consistently and i
really want to encourage a more balanced
approach
before working through thatcher what's
the base oh goodness gracious the
skateboarders are always in the house my
first non-biological family was a
skateboarding community when i i i've
great relationship with my parents now
but because there was a time when there
was no one to go to soccer games or do
any of that stuff the skateboard
community took me in because there were
no parents involved it was great there
were no referees or coaches because i
didn't like authority and it was it was
awesome and there was no nutritional
plan you drank your slurpee and you sat
on the curb and it was fantastic
i don't do that anymore but the
skateboarding community is one that i've
remained close with um i did write for
thrasher under a different name while i
was a postdoc to make some extra cash um
you won't find those articles anywhere i
hope um
they're not very good
and uh
best skater i was involved in it enough
that i'd this only makes sense to like
three people in the audience but i had a
decent heel flip i could nollie better
than i could ollie and i was never very
good and i just other more skateboarders
in the audience what i will say though
is you have to be very careful with
skateboarders because i don't want to
claim that i was any good any any um
success that i had was out of sympathy
of others for letting me hang around it
was a it's a great community and it gave
me great appreciation for indeed
communities of kids that don't have uh
you know structure and and sports
leagues and teams and all that kind of
stuff nowadays it's it's actually a much
different landscape and i have to also
say what it's
really amazing to see all the incredible
um girls and women skateboarders also
there were none
it's olympic sport now for women and
girls and for and and it's an olympic
sport for for boys and men too so it's
um it's awesome to see that community
okay what are your favorite brain hacks
for doing hard things ranging from cold
exposure to getting through
getting through selection hobie darling
thanks for the question yeah um
hard things well i'll i'll be honest i
learned how to hack into my adrenaline
system a long time ago through the worst
possible mechanism which is that i would
set up battles in my mind i would i
would get into competition with people
imagined or real or i would
get into states of fearing uh shame and
um
you know screwing up so i would you can
this is what a lot of people do i think
you end up scaring yourself into trying
to do the hard thing and it works
the problem is it it feels rather um
like a downward spiral because
those negative states of mind work to
liberate adrenaline and get you in in
through hard things so being you know as
a kind of rebellious kid you know
resistance was if someone told me i
couldn't do something i was like yeah
try me um this kind of thing and i as i
mentioned before i wasn't crazy about
authority and so that was the method for
a long time and then then i started
reading oliver sax's books and i started
learning from people who seem to access
things through this whole love thing
though and i tried that love and
kindness meditation thing and that
didn't work and
what i started doing was i actually i'll
just tell you when i
before i came out here tonight and
before i do anything challenging i i
just actually like to imagine
the people that have supported me it's a
it's a weird tool i don't think i've
ever shared i'm actually slightly
embarrassed to share this out because
there are only two things that make me
cry and that's talking about my bulldog
and talking about my graduate advisor
and if i talk about any longer i'll
probably cry but i think about them a
lot
um because they were kind of similar
um
they were kind of ornery and they were
hard on me and
and i adored them both and so i these
days i try and think about people that
uh that really that i love and so i have
been trying to do this whole like doing
things from a place of love thing and so
for me that's animals and people uh that
i love
has and how's okay now now i am better
move on so oh thank you
okay they're telling me one more
question so i'm going to answer one what
do i fear how do you manage your fear kb
oh gosh this is going to turn into a
no one's going to be satisfied until i
cry i get it
i get it
um i do cry but again about the things i
mentioned before i realized something by
the way we just recorded an episode on
grief it hasn't come out yet uh
fascinating topic um i realized at one
point by the way i'll just give this
away that um
i thought i was really sad
about losing them i thought i would tear
up really easily because i was sad about
them but then i realized this gosh i
can't believe i'm gonna do this but i
realized that feeling that i was feeling
is the exact same feeling of love that i
had when they were alive so grief is
love and when you look at the literature
it's it's basically that but your brain
is freaking out because that map of
knowing where people are in space and
time grief is basically a remapping of
the space where are they time when are
they and then this
kind of abstract map representation that
we call closeness and grief is this
process of like ripping ourselves off of
that so in any event what do i fear
talking about things like this
um
what do i fear um
quite honestly
my biggest fear the thing that would
just make me feel
just
horrible is i i fear letting down my
friends i have an amazing
i love my family and they're wonderful
but i have this in incredible
relationship to friendship
and um
i just i adore my friends and i would
sooner
give up all my limbs and die before i
would i would deliberately let them down
so there you go that's what i fear most
i also fear i've gone long and so my
team has shut this down i just want to
just briefly um
uh two things uh first of all i
i of course want to thank everyone for
coming here tonight um i realize it's
the middle of the week and to commit
some hours of your life to thinking
about these brain mechanisms we got
pretty nerdy there for a minute um and
hopefully the tools uh
redeemed those uh who were only uh
interested or mostly interested in
practical tools but hopefully some of
the insights about how you work were
useful as well i do want to just make
brief mention of the sponsors that made
this possible because they did make this
possible and we made every effort to try
and keep the ticket prices manageable
for people and thanks to inside tracker
and momentous for making this possible
and then of course i would be completely
remiss if i didn't say
thank you for your interest in science
[Applause]
thank you
thanks so much
everyone be sure to get home safely
tonight